check  yeah on the clock but they're repeating  but also black and if he wants to  take on D3 and on G2 yeah  but that's the scary end game  I think so yeah yeah probably no point  at least  I didn't even realize that white is  threatening mate  yeah draw wow  what an incredible fight yeah  yeah  and there we see the repetition and then  look at this the disappointment on  Wesley's face that he cannot believe  that he did not manage to win this yeah  it will not be so easy for him to play  Black yeah not at all after this  Marathon game and after missing the  chance you definitely feel like you you  missed the big chance  definitely definitely